ladies and gentlemen welcome to the i
have gray in my hair i gotta stop i
gotta i i i went to the hairstylist
today to get the gray out
and i i walked in and just immediately
laughed because i could see
that it was gonna be a horror and i you
like west hollywood salons or it's like
a lot of very peppy gay men and then and
very like brain dead women and gay men
it's like that unholy alliance
of gay men and very stupid women yeah
and everyone's very perky and i just
said i can't even do this so but i'm
taping a special on saturday and i want
to
i want to look like i'm 17 years old so
i want to get some of the gray out
because i have nice hair but it's gray
it becomes a problem you have a great
head of hair it's all i have it doesn't
matter
you know what i mean it has no
effect it's like i have nice eyes you
know what i mean you do
yeah you're a handsome guy that's lovely
i do well with older women and lesbians
yeah i find myself attracted to you
which is yes i know and you know maureen
at truetv always wanted to [ __ ] you know
and you know it's always like
and i was always like ah
okay i'm good
jessica kirsten is the funniest woman in
america i really believe that that's it
everyone rogan and me we all talk about
it you are
and we just so you destroy at the laugh
factory you destroy everywhere you go if
you're not following jessica you should
it's at jessica kirsten on twitter it's
very [ __ ] simple
it's very easy
and she's on the road all the time
you're on the road and we were just
talking about the hell that the road is
it's horrific yeah it's a nightmare it's
a [ __ ] i mean it's why i do it
because i'm a miserable [ __ ] person
so it's very familiar for me it's it's a
you get into a good rhythm yeah yeah
yeah i mean i don't think i'd be okay if
i if if i wasn't doing that because it
would be just boring well it's also
we're addicts yeah and addicts love
like a like a depressing hotel oh yeah
horrible coffee it tastes like urine
yeah ass juice
urine is actually would taste better
than what the coffee tastes like yeah
there's something about a nice
depressing there's something that's
standing on the side of the road
and just watching cars pass by yeah that
there's something soothing about that to
people that are very [ __ ] up and like
you said to me how many bags do i bring
so i'm going away for a month i'm like i
don't bring any i just go to the dxl the
fat store and i buy three
black 3xl shirts and sometimes i just
throw them out
i just picture you like just throwing
them just on the street no i look like a
terrorist when i get on the plane
because i have nothing
i mean i have nothing
and i look like a guy that's on the
brink of something so they kind of size
me up they literally sometimes go that's
all you're bringing i go yeah
and then i just have to drive in the fat
store dxl is always 30 to 40 minutes out
of a city
because they're ashamed of it as they
should be so they put it so far out into
the suburbs you have to drive 30 minutes
it's not even in the suburbs in
something called the exurbs which is
like 45 minutes out
that's the new term for it where it's so
far out
that you have to
uh keep driving past all the paneras and
you know and then you get there finally
and you get the three shirts and then
you wear them and you throw them out or
you bring them back or whatever what if
you're in like europe or something do
they have like fat stores let me tell
you right now
i will wear one outfit i don't know what
to do no i'm gonna have to pack for
europe but the thing you have to pack
for yourself i'm not gonna be home
before europe so i have to buy clothing
and luggage
well they might have like a bed bath and
beyond you can get like curtains or
something yeah no i i'm gonna go to
europe and
i will i will not be able to purchase
anything yeah so i have to then like
cover myself you've been doing comedy a
bit a long time yeah i started in 99 so
i've been in this nightmare of a
situation
for 23 years
when you started was it were people
smoking in comedy clubs was it that type
of environment what kind of environment
was it
no but they weren't smoking but they
were laughing and you could say anything
you wanted that i was i started during
that time that time yeah when it was you
were free to say whatever you wanted
yeah people came to laugh yeah and they
didn't think about every joke right now
they analyzed yeah now i say something
and there's this moment of like is it
okay to laugh at that right so
yeah but you see what i do i just plow
through
you either laugh or you don't you know
that's why everybody respects you you
just don't give a [ __ ] um i i do it a
little bit but i i i don't i just have
to just do it and it's like whatever
happens happens you gotta just go i'm
barely functioning so i i now go up and
play sometimes like obviously i go up in
rooms where they you know people don't
know me i've had the luxury is going up
in a lot of rooms where people know me
now because they come to see me
it's so much more fun and then i go out
and i say something and then there's
like a soccer mom who's like you know
what i mean and who thinks she's an
environmentalist because she has a tesla
never mind where that lithium ion comes
from whatever who cares
uh but they they they make the face they
you know they do the whole thing and
it's like and i'm not even attracted to
women so for me
i i have no you know it there's nothing
there i go we're on a bad date
and it's who will end soon enough
and then we'll just be done with that
yeah you know yeah it's i mean people
have completely lost their minds we were
just talking about that especially here
in la it's i mean we're both sober and i
feel like i've taken 70 drugs things
that aren't even i don't know what's
going on yeah well people here in la
will say they're sober but they do all
of the drugs they're on crack i said
that to you like people will say i'm i'm
california sober i'm like you're on
crystal meth yeah you're literally just
shot people will tell you they do
shrooms and none of the people doing
shrooms are having any of the
revelations you'd hope they'd have yeah
like none of these people are like
progressing in any area of their life no
they're taking shrooms they're going to
joshua tree they're sitting at under the
stars yeah and i don't know what's
happening i don't know if they're taking
dmt and the aliens are appearing i don't
know if they're arguing with the aliens
or the aliens like here's the way it is
and they're like well actually i don't
know what's going on but none of it
is uh
were you ever tempted to be like oh i
can be sober but do psychedelics no
to me being sober is sober i i can't do
anything because it always leads to
other if that's right if i start smoking
pot i'm gonna suck a guy's [ __ ] on the
street corner and like
you know
i mean and i'm gay like it's not this is
not good i can't do anything it's not a
good situation no matter what i can't do
anything but their struggles to struggle
their food
everything everything i'll do anything
i'm a garbage can yeah i'm out of my
mind everything's a struggle yeah when
did you get sober
i mean i've been in and out for years
you know but there's been times when
i've had you know six years at a time
eight years at a time right but again
anytime i thought i could do a little
something and what usually gets you like
what's the thing that pot so that's why
i'm saying like people that say i'm
sorry i've done that with cigarettes
i've quit cigarettes
30 to 40 times in in my life really yeah
i was i was six years off them once
yeah yeah cigarettes are tough
it's very tough it's brutality yeah and
they're not even fun here's the thing
about cigarettes they're disgusting yeah
they smell bad you feel horrible
when you don't smoke you feel so much
better yeah but it is the it's one of
the greatest products
because it can raise the price of it
italy it kills you in 19 different ways
and no matter how long like i used to be
five years without a cigarette and i'd
see somebody smoking a cigar and i go
damn i know
damn that looks good everyone misses
them it's a very oral thing
it's calming it's a it's it's tough it's
that was the hardest believe it or not
that i think that was the hardest thing
i ever had to quit it was very hard very
hard to quit it was very hard and and i
and i i don't now thank god now i i
don't do it
but i know you really know i'm really
proud of you i'm proud of you for
quitting i have said to people in l.a i
don't smoke cigarettes anymore while
smoking cigarette they've looked at me
went good job man yeah because they're
so self-involved they're not even
noticing that you're smoking right
disgusting that's kind of the benefit of
living here you lie to each other's
faces and everyone believes that yeah
yeah you can say i don't drink anymore
while you're downing a beer and people
are like that's great
so happy
i could face [ __ ] myself with like a
donut and you're like i don't need sugar
and they're like that's great with like
powder all over my eyes
no one listens to anyone here it's not
they're not even nobody's even paying
attention what do you think makes us
addicts
well i i don't know i mean nature is it
nurture i think it's i think it's a lot
of things i mean i i i don't know i
don't know if i was born this way i mean
i'm from a family of food addicts so i
you know i'm from drunks i'm irish
catholic we're from drunks we're from
repressed sexuality i have an aunt who
you know has never been with a man and
she wears men's shoes and
you know what i mean not because she's a
lesbian because they're more comfortable
you know
and uh you know and she wears a strap
she had like a special friend in college
they were very close
so it's like men's shoes is my favorite
yeah no i mean she she walks around the
house like storming around and like
mentions
so it's it's this is we come from these
places that have my mother's is
schizophrenic
you know and uh you know but now the
country is caught up to her
yeah like we locked her up 20 years ago
but now everyone is kind of saying what
she's said for years
so it's like i talk to regular people
and they say things similar to what my
mother said because the country has now
become kind of schizophrenic too it is
totally so we should let her out you
should let her out she should just right
around she'll be fine just send her to
the capitol and buy her a a [ __ ]
viking hat
send her in she'll [ __ ] on the desk and
it'll be totally normal
yeah what what is your because a lot of
people call me and they go
or not call me but they message me and
they go
what is the best way to get sober i did
a.a for a while i should go to more
meetings i don't really go to too many
meetings
uh what is the best way in your
estimation to change your life
from
from being
a drug addict or an alcoholic
or a food addict or whatever to being
sober kill yourself
no i hate
[Music]
jump in front of a car no
this is honestly
i it's a hard question i hate saying
this yeah because it's annoying
but the program is the only way that it
is it really is the only way and i i'm a
child of a therapist
uh i've been to every single therapy
every [ __ ] therapist done everything
and it always comes back to that it's
the only way um for me that that's work
no you're right and i also think you
know uh being honest and working with
other alcoholics and helping people and
getting out of my own head because i'm a
selfish [ __ ] um
it's a lot of things but but working the
program and working the steps has been
the only way i've been able to stay
sober and i've tried a lot of other
things i've tried i've tried doing it on
my own i've tried everything
um i'm the most sane when i work another
program and i i mean work a program and
and i hate saying that because i hate
having to have something yeah that helps
me like i have to do that ben doesn't
ben was lucky because he didn't need the
program on the program for him yeah so
it's very lucky sometimes people have a
mentor that comes in
not everyone is lucky enough to have
someone like me who's relentlessly
positive and life-affirming oh ben
you're so lucky yeah
it's a real treat but i mean what
happened to the doctor the other day he
said to you he took all your blood you
said you're healthy and then what did he
say well i am low on vitamin d he said
i'm deficient on that but he said my
biggest health risk is just uh relapsing
yeah he goes because he goes don't look
up the
the numbers on it but the rate of
relapse is severely high yeah doctors
are always positive here
very high are you sober ben i am sober
four years uh wow that's great tim
helped me oh that's amazing yeah
it's a fun
it's a fun
we have it's an aaa meeting every day
here
i miss you guys
if you guys don't work the program you
must be at each other's throats
sometimes we're not at each other's
throats there's a lot of tension we
should work the program that's something
we should do more i did
i did the steps i did everything yeah it
works it does work it's it's good
especially you know in early sobriety
and even long-term sobriety you have to
do it
especially yeah in long-term sobriety
because you get you know once you're
comfortable that's cocky yeah exactly
and you go it'll be okay especially in
this in this business that we're in it's
you know people tend to be
yeah there's good support with comics
there's a lot there's a bunch of sober
comics and there's a very good support
system
you know um and it's it's helpful
because this business is just
makes me want to you know shoot up
heroin into my anus
it makes me want to put a needle in my
[ __ ] you have a
you have a beautiful wife who's lovely
thank you yeah she's great and you have
children what's it like raising kids in
this world i'm never home so i don't
even raise them right it's really um
as long as they're attractive that's all
i care about yeah yeah thank god they're
pretty i have four daughters and they're
all stunning thank god because i really
one of your daughter's amazing singer i
mean these are talented people yeah zoe
is almost 16. she goes to we live in
long island so i love that connection to
you and and she goes to the school for
performing arts there half the day she's
an amazing actress and singer do you
ever do you ever like worry about her
getting into the business yes but she
does you know they don't get as affected
by the rejection and [ __ ] she's pretty
and she has an agent she's a buck wall
and she auditions all the time i mean
she does get bogged down by it but she's
pretty good with it uh but yeah of
course it's it's and and she's there's
so many girls that look and she's a
stunning right dark hair you know blue
eye like there's a lot of girls that
look like her and a lot of stuff is is
going to other girls now that's the
truth it's right so um
so there's that and then i have a
six-year-old daughter and i have twin
three-year-olds you know i have two baby
mamas it's [ __ ] crazy it's wild yeah
and do you get along with both of them i
do i do i mean it's i'm i'm i'm lucky i
i have a good situation
i can't believe i have all these kids i
never thought i'd have one kid but i
couldn't say no now did you do surrogate
did you do i we did in vitro as they so
each of them you know my my ex sherry
had zoe and then danielle my current
wife had isabella madison and charlotte
and you've had none of them no i would
never have a kid i'd feel like i was
like
i i'm very male in a lot of ways so i
would i've never
for one second thought of carrying a
child like i would feel like i was an
ali
all day about being implanted and
carrying a child really
yes i think it's an inevitability that i
get pregnant and have a child wow
no i i really like it
i like the idea of being entitled and
angry and having cravings and calling
ben at 3am i go get me pickles
and you know he goes like you know i i
buy all these dumb houses and [ __ ] and
stuff i don't even live in them and it's
just because i'm an addict so i just
love real estate yeah i just love
realtors and going in and out of houses
going to open houses we go to open
houses that's ria
and uh but it's also good to put money
in pla because my business manager will
steal and i mean he's a sweetheart but
he'll steal yeah and and i think he's
he's pretty you know i mean the first
time we met him he'd come from five guys
he had mustard on him i said oh he'll
take
our money as soon as we have enough of
it you know he's he's talking about
racing nft horses i mean the guy's he's
on the ledge yeah and so what what what
you know but that's something like you
know ben always tells me like don't do
this don't do this don't you don't need
this you're not even gonna enjoy it but
i think it'll be funny when i have a
baby in me and ben will be like i told
you not to do this what would you rather
have a girl or a boy just so we can know
because you can kind of plan that i'd
like a girl okay and i'd like a girl
because they're i i have the perfect
idea of what a woman should be
i think you know for and more than
anyone
i know what a woman should be and with
guys you know i i you know they kind of
just go their own way i
have a real idea of what a a woman
should be in my estimation and what
should a woman be um or just some
examples i'm curious
you know my dream daughter
is a
very cold
yeah and withholding woman
i like that yeah no and i'm attracted to
that yeah a very you know pretty
or even if she's not pretty
cold and withholding
and i feel like there's too much
nurturing going on right now yeah and i
i think women should go back to being
cold and withholding and a little
aloof
i like a woman who smokes a cigarette
and stares at the sky yeah i like a
little aloofness there's two
people are p it's overdone now mm-hmm
and i i like that and i would i don't
know how i would create that in a person
but i would try definitely you can
damage her yeah no that would be the
goal and intimacy issues that would be
the hope yeah you don't hug her too much
and you if you if you're very
inconsistent that would help because i
think that those types of women
select an appropriate mate
because there's a lot of women that make
very bad decisions
with who they choose to spend their
lives with yeah and i think i would like
my daughter to be kind of really
evaluate a guy on a bunch of different
levels and go
i'm getting into a partnership with you
does doesn't make sense yeah do you ever
worry that your daughters may choose
uh to be with someone who's not good yes
a lot
a lot
you know i i i
i zoe i i trust zoe zoey's very like
free spirited and like yeah and kind of
a little
um
you know she thinks everyone's good and
kind of
like naive a little bit so that scares
me but i'm very like clear with her and
so is my ex about how like people can be
really
horrible right and evil at times because
that's honest you know that's real and
i'm like you got to be really careful
like people are not what's good is like
you're involved my family's always been
so uninvolved in my life yeah they're
not involved in any respect like my dad
is a fan of mine but it's like he's not
he's not involved he doesn't really ask
like is it what's going on are you
dating someone do you feel okay are you
alive it's very much like you'll call me
and go david spade mentioned do you want
howard stern isn't it it's all about the
business yeah it's all about the
business so which is fine right but it
is it is
i we i was raised by the worst
generation of people on earth the boomer
and the boomer did and i've conducted an
exhaustive survey of the boomer
the boomer
not all of them but a lot of them it was
a generation of
terribly selfish people yeah
terribly selfish
that are constantly aggrieved
their entire lives have been a struggle
even though when you when you look it
hasn't been
houses were cheap cars were cheap
the land was theirs to pillage and they
did yeah um
and they believed that kids were
obstacles to their own fulfillment and
their fulfillment involved golf and wine
uh it was not
per se
uh you know
you know they were like they were the
hippies
and they just turned hard away from that
and they kept all because hippie you
know that culture was all about like
exploring yourself and but it had a lot
of spiritual components so what they did
when they came out of that is they they
kept the self
that that culture had and lost all of
the spirituality and just became very
selfish people and i'm not i'm not
saying anything bad about um my parents
other than the fact that they like
shouldn't have been parents
yeah well i mean most people i think a
lot of people shouldn't be paranoid but
i'm happy they were or tried yeah yeah
they weren't abusive they didn't they
didn't burn me with cigarettes
well i think you i know a lot about your
life you know and you had a tough time
it was tough it was not the best it
wasn't it was not the best wasn't it but
my parents have let me know that was a
lot was had to do with me
i know it was my fault i know which is
which is horrific
it's horrific now now
the outcome is your brilliance well
that's very sweet that's very true
that's right that's why you're so
talented and brilliant yeah and and we
become
i do think that i am
funny because i went through so much
pain i think that humor com i don't
think i know that humor comes from pain
and i don't i think the funniest people
have been hurt the most that's my
personal opinion right you know when
people go on stage and they're so
[ __ ] funny i'm like that person has
gone through [ __ ] right i really believe
that for sure um you ever look at comics
you haven't been through anything and
you go what are you doing oh yeah i'm
like you're too okay yeah you're like
why are you doing this there's so many
comics who are just clever i never laugh
at clever comedy
and i have people do like they'll do
well on stage louie said something great
once it's like i forget did louis say it
i forget who said i think it was louis
where it was like it's comedy for people
who went to vassar yeah yeah yeah it was
some it might not have been louis but
somebody it was like that type of
where it's like it's very it's very well
thought out
yeah i've never laughed at seinfeld now
he's a great writer i've never once
laughed at it here's the most brilliant
thing because he's technically one of
the most brilliant comics i'm i'm sure
he loves him he'd love me
uh that's sarcastic but
um
what the one time i really laughed at
him is he did a speech for the clio
advertising awards where he goes
uh it was the funniest thing that i've
ever seen him do because it was the most
real bet ben can get it up
this is him being the most real i've
ever hold on one second this is him
being the most real
i've ever seen it is my one of my
favorite things i've ever seen a comic
do because the thing with him is
some of his jokes are so technically
brilliant they're brilliant
brilliant writers
there is
sort of you feel like you you feel like
you don't know him and that's my thing
that's what i'm saying i i this is just
my personal opinion but here if you
watch this this to me
is one of the best things cause now i do
kind of feel like i know him if you
watch this
i am excited to win this this
this is the award they give you when
they don't think you can actually win
one
but they think you've done a pretty good
job and seem to have been around for
quite some time
and that's how i got it
i would like to thank ogilvy and
maythere in american express for getting
me into this business
that was the first time i did it i would
like to thank my manager george shapiro
my incredible wife jessica
and amarati for keeping me going
i love advertising
because i love lying
in advertising everything is the way
you wish it was i don't care
that it won't be like that when i
actually get the product being
advertised because in between seeing the
commercial and owning the thing
i'm happy
and that's all i want
tell me how great the thing is going to
be i love it i don't need to be happy
all the time
i just want to enjoy the commercial
i want to get the thing we know the
product is going to stink we know that
because we live in the world and we know
that everything stinks
we all believe hey maybe this one won't
stink
we are a hopeful species
stupid but hopeful
but we're happy in that moment between
the commercial and the purchase and i
think spending your life trying to dupe
innocent people
out of hard-won earnings to buy useless
low-quality
misrepresented items and services is an
excellent use of your energy
that's different than what he does
that's right this is why i love it here
keep watching this is great
because a brief moment of happiness is
pretty good
i also think that just focusing on
making money and buying stupid things is
a good way of life
i believe materialism gets a bad rap
it's not about the amount of money
nothing's better than a bic pen a vw
beetle or a pair of regular levi's
if your things don't make you happy
you're not getting the right things
this will all be in my new book soulful
materialism which is in the planning
stages
at this moment
i have always wanted a clio
i don't know much about it
but i know it's a good award
because in 1991 they screwed up this
whole presentation
and there were a bunch of awards left
over and all of these ad people here
climbed up onto the stage and tried to
grab them
so to me that says this means something
that really happened and it's my
all-time favorite award show occurrence
because it was so honest
people just said i want a damn clio and
they went for it
and that is why i am happy right now
i got this
i didn't really win it but i got it
and tomorrow i don't know where this is
gonna be it'll be somewhere
eventually i'll be dead someone will
just take it or sell it or throw it out
and that's fine i'm happy now
the same way those executives were in
1991 when they ran onto this stage and
grabbed trophies that weren't theirs
[Applause]
but it trumped up their phony careers in
meaningless lives
so thank you all i mean it's like so
that
i saw that i was like this is like
this moment it's real yeah it's totally
real and dark and dark but he's not
i've watched him a million times it's
not his usual thing it's safe and it's
not
real a lot it's just yeah it's a
different thing yeah it's a different
thing what do you think
like is happening
you know with comedy right now where you
have a lot of comics who are cool
and you have a lot of people that seem
like
they are on stage to make a point
[Music]
and
they feel like they're a gay comic
or they're a comic of color or they're a
comic or they're a trans comic it
doesn't feel like the community of
comics feels more divided and splintered
now than it's kind of ever been
it feels like the identity of comic
to me is such a powerful strong identity
it should unite all these different
groups of people
under that umbrella it doesn't seem to
anymore it seems to be weirdly
balkanized or everybody's kind of doing
their own thing it is yeah it is divided
um
a lot of comics have gone
at each other which i am not used to it
was very united for my entire career
yeah and now um people are incredibly
judgmental of each other i i personally
have never judged comics for what they
do so it's very odd for me to see
comics going at each other yeah um i i
could hate someone's act
be disgusted by it um
hear what they have to say and want to
vomit and want them to die
but i still believe they have the right
to say it
so uh yeah and i just you know i i laugh
at what's funny
and i just think the funniest people
should get hired for work that's right
so it's just i don't know what's going
on good luck with that point i know
i just keep doing what i do and saying
what i say and i don't let anyone
silence me in long island do you ever
encounter homophobia
oh not in long island um
i mean i word things and say things in a
certain way so that i make people feel
absolutely ridiculous if they were to be
homophobic from my material right
but when i'm on the road
right um i definitely get some people
that get tense
right um and it's more of like the
religious people i remember when i first
started on long island there was a lot
of weirdness i would
say something about being gay people
would go and that's not a huge part of
my act i have one or two jokes yeah me
yeah about it but it was weird back then
people be like oh what like what like it
was a different time but things have
gotten a lot
things have changed a lot a lot of
people don't want to admit that or they
don't believe that but
first-hand experience i think people's
attitudes have changed they've changed a
lot and i gotta tell you they're a
little more homophobic with men
sure when it comes to comedy absolutely
definitely absolutely i think with women
there's never been a big gay male comic
stand no right no no
not at all i mean the no
i'm thinking about it
out of the closet there's never been a
big gay male stand-up comic no i'd say
you're
by far the biggest there's ever been
by far well
i mean you don't talk about it a lot but
i mean you're out and you're
the most famous there's ever been that
i'm sorry that's crazy to think about i
don't know if that's the case yes it is
i mean there's mario cantone but he's
he's not i mean it's not at your level
as a stand-up i'm just saying as an
actor
but he's musical and it's different
right there's i don't know who el and
he's not it's not the same thing i'm
just saying he's cause there's no
because there's an ellen there's alan
right ellen's a male comic who's
comic than you are
that's true but as lesbians they've had
big comics huge they've had huge
lesbians my god sarah sandra there's
tons of them
tons right um
but no there isn't i i'd say you're that
you are that's wild yeah i don't know i
mean think about it i've never thought
about it but yeah i've never i don't
either but that's a real statement i've
always just never
knew that but i never i also never
like people and it's weird like
i understand people's point when they
say representation matters you know i
want to see myself someone that looks
like me doing something i totally get
that
maybe i i don't know i never saw that
but i never cared
i don't care either it's such a small i
never care like i never saw a big gay
male comic but i never
cared it didn't make me think it was off
the table
i know i don't think about that stuff i
just think about who's funny like i
don't right
but it's also aren't we we're kind of a
different generation of gay people yeah
we are there's a there's another
generation of gay people who are they
don't they have sex with the members of
the opposite sex right so that's
different gay has gotten very it's a big
tent now you don't have to be gay to be
gay in fact it's a detriment
you can be
queer there's a there's a big tent and a
lot of the people that are in it are are
married and heterosexual you are telling
me that in the car and i am very
confused by it on twitter today came out
as queer i mean you can get i don't
understand yeah i'm not judging it i
don't know what you're talking about
though
yeah i'm judging it a little but you
know what it is understand what you were
saying you said
he's married to a woman yeah he goes
i've started identifying his queer over
the last four months does that make me
the new queer but in all black i think
most men especially black men like me
who come out later in life because we
don't really know it ourselves also i'm
attracted to a wide range of women but
not men at all so i didn't know how to
id myself even though i haven't felt
straight in years lol so i don't know
what that means
i have no idea i mean
i'm not hating on it i genuinely am
confused
to me i literally feel like i just heard
chinese right i have absolutely no idea
it might be a chinese bot but it's
you know i i i i that to me makes
again
i'm i'd love to understand it
i would love that's the success of the
gay movement that straight people now
want to be in it
and then the big lol at the end is a
very upsetting
because it's yes what is that that's a
crazy person but it's a that
many people are ill we're living in a
what do you think the percentage of
mental illness now in the country is 30
40
98 and a half
[Laughter]
now in certain ways i'm mentally ill but
i work on it and i'm medicated yeah
right
i mean i'm not judging like i ha i have
issues but i work on it
people are out of their minds i we were
at a comedy club i told you i was at a
comedy club last night it looked like
the game room in a mental institution
and i'm not even just talking about the
comics i'm talking about the audience
too the people that work there i'm like
am i at
a mental institution people were like
rocking back and forth someone was
talking themselves someone was flicking
their fingers someone was rocking there
was a person
with a helmet i don't know what the [ __ ]
was going on someone was defecating it
was the cr i'm like this country is out
of everyone's crazy yeah
and i really
constantly feel like i'm on a sheet of
acid not even one little like i'm on a
sheet
of a heroic toast
yeah i've taken a a a cardboard like
sheet of acid what do you think it is
you think it's the internet's driven
people crazy yes yes my mom says that
she's a huge therapist and she said the
internet has ruined people's life i mean
it's
ruined like she
said it's ruined people's lives
and it's only getting more and more
intense i mean it's insane i can
subscribe do you ever
do you ever go through tick tock and
just go through it like crazy it's it's
out of control it's out of control like
you'll just see someone like hi everyone
i'm dorothy and i really and then you
just flick through and it's like
[Music]
and it's just one person after the neck
like mentally ill [ __ ] crazy people
it's nuts yeah
it's crazy
well there's a lot of neuro divergence
now
[Laughter]
it's true i mean there's a there's a lot
of people that are that are on the
spectrum and they are
struggling with different things and it
only see there's more and more of that
and now that's becoming kind of a brand
in a weird way there's someone who
literally
is mentally [ __ ] or whatever you
want to call it right
and
they're
700 pounds
okay
in like a tight t-shirt and boxers
with one sock on
like
like just singing and then it has 786
000 shares like it's just being made fun
of everywhere
i love keeps people losing their hair is
disgusting and so you got to go to keeps
keeps offers a simple affordable
stress-free way to keep all of your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door every three months you don't
have to leave your home 24 7 care and
support keeps as a network of expert
medical advisors prescribers and care
specialists to support you in making
your hair goals a reality remember
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
fast when it comes to your hair save
more spend less if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon
receive your first month of treatments
for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
tim dillon to get your first month of
treatments for free k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dillon a lot of my
friends are using keeps everyone loves
keeps
uh
you know
being bald is tough unless you're rogan
who's you know very driven and a
trillionaire but you're not so don't
lose your hair
k-e-e-p-s dot com tim dillon expressvpn
companies are always trying to sell you
things and and mine your data and sell
your data so what you got to do is i've
been using expressvpn to binge all kinds
of cool shows on netflix because you can
watch all the net the netflix
uh all the other countries netflix you
love korean drama expressvpn uh to
parasite off south korea netflix haha
but it's not just netflix expressvpn
works with any streaming service hulu
bbc iplayer youtube you name it there
are hundreds of vpns out there but the
reason i love expressvpn is to watch
shows is because it's ridiculously fast
there's never any buffering or lag and
you can stream in hd no problem
expressvpn also works on all your
devices phones media consoles smart tvs
and more so you can watch what you want
on the go or on the big screen
so if you want to get access to hundreds
of new shows use my link right now at
expressvpn.com tim dillon and you can
get an extra three months of expressvpn
for free that's expressvpn.com
timdale and expressvpn.com tim dylan to
learn more uh you use the vpn what do
you think about it uh it's i always have
it on when i'm uh doing things for the
show or logging into things i mean you
just you don't want to not use a vpn
anymore it makes zero sense you gotta
use it and it's an app and it's easy
it's easy you click it boom you're done
you gotta do and it supports our show so
if you enjoy the show please support
expressvpn what do you think of the pro
fat movement now it's very interesting
the fat activism
i mean i
yeah i've been as people who've
struggled with our weight it's
interesting to see now it's gone the
other way where fat people are like
threatening people on social media
330 pounds and no one should have been
promoting me
i
i was
disgusting
and should have been shot i should have
been
hunted down and shot i was not i was
a
i should have gotten help someone should
have
someone should have gotten a net
and [ __ ]
put me in a cage and help me
but there's a movement now well i needed
movement i needed a lot of movement
because i was dying yeah okay there's a
movement to celebrate
i should have not been celebrated i had
i had
rashes yes
i mean i was i was not okay
but
what has happened
you know what i mean like what has
happened where
it it's gone to a place
where
there is a celebration
of
that type of behavior
well i think that no i don't think
fat people should be
victimized or treated like [ __ ] no but
no one thinks that
of course not but we've gone to in such
an extreme
place i have a lot of fat professionals
my agent is fat and they're very
distracted they're fat
my tour is booked
if you look at the way my tour is booked
it's booked in towns with steakhouses so
that my agent can come i have a fat
assistant she's lovely
but she's distracted because they're
always thinking about eating i'm
surprised your tour isn't all at like
burger kings yeah no my tour is
literally routed around the openings of
steakhouses
and but
you know
it is a distracting thing like i'm
trying to lose weight it's hard
do they always have food in their mouths
when you're talking to them they're
chewing they're crunching lately
they crunch things they have little
vittles that they have
they've got food everywhere like you
know it's distracting it's like again
it's a compulsion
i know you don't have to tell me i'm an
animal i [ __ ] my face with food i don't
even chew you know what it is i know so
to me the idea that that's become a
celebrated part of our society it's not
okay it's not okay
the mukbangs online
you've seen them people just eat people
watching
i mean did you see nick avocado's video
where the woman was getting stabbed yeah
i sent that chair please bring that out
someone's getting stabbed there's a
woman in an apartment building getting
stabbed
and i don't know if you even know who
this guy is this guy
all he does is eat online and he
eats these crazy things and he's just
kind of killing himself
online
every day he's pretty popular and he's
very pop people want to watch him kill
himself with food this is a deeply
disturbed society now i want you to
listen to this because this is literally
true
someone's getting stabbed to death in
the apartment next door and they notice
it and they keep eating watch this
okay they taste like this but
you know hello
screams grease here
play it again and i want you to listen
for the screams you can hear him okay
you can literally hear the screams
okay they taste like this but
you know
i mean you hear somebody in the
background
so somebody's you know that he just made
me homophobic and i'm married to a woman
yeah yeah yeah like i want to suck dick
after watching that yeah yeah
it's so disturbing because there's
people
millions of them watching this type of
stuff it's it's there's something that
the the internet's unlocked which is
really terrible
that's so disturbing watching him eat
like that yeah it's really bad
it's
yeah it's not good so he's really
popular he's very popular i've watched a
lot of his stuff he just eats for hours
he goes crazy now why do you watch it
you sick [ __ ] i i don't really know why
when you're really hungry and you want
fast food late at night if you just
watch him eat a bunch of tacos from
jack-in-the-box or something uh soothing
about it there's something and it's also
kind of funny and morbid and is he just
talking while he's eating yeah he tells
he has a little anecdotes and he has his
boyfriend uh orlan i think olin or
orland
and they do cooking recipes too so
they'll cook ramen noodles with cheese
and eat those and show you recipes and
he'll go around target in a rascal
scooter and do little sk skits and stuff
and so this is where we are this is a
and they're famous they're famous yeah
yeah and i'm going to do six shows at
the [ __ ]
chuckle bunnies yeah
yeah
well you know
but this is really disturbing stuff and
your mother is a therapist probably is
she probably has just some very
interesting uh you know thoughts and
ideas about
how it got this bad
i mean i think that we are voyeur like i
think people just want to watch this and
just get hooked in i mean we it's like
watching the war you know the news and
all that [ __ ] we get hooked in and it's
that addictive personality that's right
we just get hooked in and we can't stop
watching yeah
yeah it's i mean it's it's it's crazy it
is crazy yeah it's unfortunate that
there are people who
[Music]
are
they're being enabled
and supported i know these really
horrible things and it's just gonna get
how is this getting better no it doesn't
you know i mean no no i i i mean i don't
know no it seems not to be
i mean my kids i i this is very
disturbing it's very hard to raise kids
in this world right with social media
and the bullying and the stuff like that
yeah yeah
it's difficult i mean you can be on top
of it and kind of you know make sure
they don't watch certain things but it's
not it's not easy it's hard to to keep
them from everything
out there it is very
very
they're gonna stumble upon things
yeah and then they they do post stuff
and they're in secret chats and they you
know for sure yeah
yeah no it's crazy it's
it's really wild now the challenge is
being apparent
and they watch the porn and all that
[ __ ] yeah
yeah i mean second base when i was
growing up was like touching a girl's
boobs now it's anal
right
yeah it's crazy
it is it's it's sped up to an unhealthy
degree
it did yeah
i mean it's bad
out there but i mean
you know what what is the good i mean
really i don't know i felt like you were
about to say like i was trying to find
what is it
uber
i don't know
postmates
yeah i know that's good you get you can
press a button and get a burrito i don't
know but then there is the the dark web
pedophile
and everything else yeah
that's a problem yeah it's a real
problem
it's hard to be funny stand up was on
stage the other night at the store and
he said something brilliant that
roseanne had said to him
it's very hard to be funny now when
there's no such thing as truth
you're living in an era where where
truth is really subjective
people don't seem to
be swayed anymore by any type of facts
they can create their own reality and
especially with the internet you can
only see that deepening
and becoming more immersive
where everybody disappears into their
own world i mean this metaverse thing
people can make fun of it and they
should and i do
but it's common
it's like everything else do you know
about the metaverse no i don't know a
lot about it get up zuckerberg the
metaverse now everything they've done
with it has been pathetic and
everybody's laughed about it so far
because like anything else it's never
going to be a thing as ray kump our
friend said it won't be a thing until
it's a thing right it's like anything
else but it really is this world where
you'll have an avatar
you'll literally pretend to to be
somebody and you'll primarily be in this
digital landscape
where you are
you know having a lot of your meaningful
relationships and interactions online
not in real life sense yeah
no it's coming here just take it take a
quick
look at it
imagine
you put on your glasses or headset and
you're instantly in your home space
it has parts of your physical home
recreated virtually it has things that
are only possible virtually and it has
an incredibly inspiring view of whatever
you find most beautiful i mean this
guy's the devil hey are you coming yeah
just gotta find something to wear
he's disgusting
all right perfect
we're floating in space who made this
place it's awesome right it's from a
crater i met in l.a
this place is amazing
baz is that you of course it's me you
know i had to be the robot man i thought
i was supposed to be the robot
whoa
i knew you were bluffing
hey wait so this is what they want
jessica
this is what they want the future to be
i'm looking at your face
but this is the plans for the future
when is this happening they're trying to
make it happen asap
but watch so they can make a lot of
money it's all yeah so that they can
basically
you know
they're trying to curate your life
they're basically trying through
algorithms and everything to feed you a
diet of what they want to feed you
you buy things in this world you consume
in this world yeah whether they're nfts
you but you use crypto whatever it is
yeah yeah and there's no touch this is
all i keep thinking there's no contact
there's no contact
there's no touch there's nothing
and you get into this world and you
purchase things in this world and you
buy real estate in this world you buy a
home in the metaverse you buy a home
and people are doing it already
and
then you don't leave and then they just
sell you things while you're there
and there you go this is the new thing
where the you know this is
the uh the demo they just ran about
here's you here's the shopping now this
is walmart this is walmart now you're
good here you shop at walmart there goes
the tomato sauce in the thing
and then it's delivered to your house
you know i don't know via drone or
whatever but why would you want tomato
sauce at your fake house well
some of this well if you have guests
do you want to make you're not going to
have pasta or something no you don't
realize how insane we are
why would you want a fake house
let's i mean let's start there
so let's start there
now i think this might be they're
demoing this is like you would order it
it would be shipped to your real house
and you would eat the tomato sauce right
right but don't i get what you don't kid
yourself fake tomato sauce for that i
mean heineken just did a thing you could
pull this up
where heineken sponsored some big
metaverse thing it was a big bomb
because everybody's like hey man what
the [ __ ] is this but this is coming
they're trying to shove it down your
throat
and make it so heineken launched some
virtual metaverse saying it was a
complete failure
uh says needless to say we all love a
frosty cold one every now and then but
now heineken is setting its sights on
bringing that element into the metaverse
brood with i'm i'm not kidding none of
this is a joke brewed with pixels and
not yeast heineken silver is the world's
first virtual
beer
so this is all coming and this is you
have the same reaction that rogan had
when i told him about this
your kids know more about this than you
do probably or will yeah this is all
coming and i'm a little bit of a
conspiracy guy
where i go they just really i mean
you'll have an avatar so if you're 400
pounds it's okay because your avatar
looks like whatever you want to
in the metaverse
and it's
a little sick
but there's an inevitability to it and
they want you on this thing
so that you can be they sell you
stuff mean it makes complete sense it
makes complete sense in even though it's
the craziest thing ever
yeah i mean you know
and i can see it like i can see it
happening i can see it being incredibly
profitable for companies and i could see
and i could see the fun of it i me too i
could see the fun of it too i go oh i i
can't afford a mansion but you know what
maybe i can in the metaverse right
you could live this whole playlist
yes forever and ever right
does it matter that the there's a
fentanyl uh a opioid epidemic yeah and
that there's violence in the streets and
that the environment is is being is uh
you know decaying and the planet is
decaying and there's political
corruption and there's no health care
and you can live a play life and so i
think this is what they're preparing
instead of fixing the problems yeah
they're going how about we all just go
to the pool party in the metaverse
that's what's coming because the
problems are deep and and very tough to
imagine solutions to as we've just said
yeah so what we think you know what i
tend to believe they're going to say is
just go to the go to the metaverse
there's already been sexual assault in
the metaverse
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh yeah
there's already been
all kinds of things sexual assault in
the metaverse
sexual harassment this is usa today
again usa today sexual harassment in the
metaverse
women alleges rape and virtual world
so so the world's ending i just want to
say that um
but it is we talked about that the whole
world is ending yeah so the world's
ending we talked about that in your
career and eddie pepiton has a great
line he goes you know every generation
thinks it's ending but we're right no we
are right you said 50 years i think less
so i'm gonna try to enjoy myself as much
as i you have to yeah
you have to enjoy yourself yeah
yeah
within 60 seconds of joining shroud i
was verbally and sexually harassed three
to four male avatars with male voices
essentially but virtually gang raped my
avatar i mean
[Laughter]
well her clothes were too tight yeah she
was out late at night yeah it was her
fault she was being too promiscuous so
this is where we are
that seems to be where we're heading
it's clownish right now
and it's not real yet but it seems to be
potentially real oh this is gonna be
huge
there's no doubt in my mind i think so
too this is coming immediately yeah i
think so too
i don't even doubt that for a second
this is this is coming out in the next
year yeah they're gonna yeah
it's coming
and i mean they're gonna encourage
people to just live
those fantasy lives oh this is for 20 30
and for this is going to be huge
that's right
and you're gonna have to pay for
everything oh yeah that's why nft is
these non-fungible tokens that you can
own digital property
and you can i don't even mean like a
house i mean like anything you could buy
an nft of a piece of art yeah or
whatever and eventually it'll be comedy
you could buy a joke yeah eventually
comedians will sell a joke yeah i'm
telling it's gonna be
it's it's all heading to that place and
it seems to be
rapidly going there
we were you know one of the last
generations
this all i guess eventually has to do
with like you know
humans becoming ai eventually there's a
chip in your head that you can write
into the metaverse
it's scary
but it is you know
i i think it'll be i hope the lineups at
the comedy clubs in the metaverse are
diverse
that's my biggest concern yeah that's my
biggest concern too yeah of anything
even like my kids is that the comedy
club lineups are diverse in the
metaverse yeah for sure yeah i mean
they'll be virtual comedy there already
are there's already virtual comedy clubs
you know darren covett yeah so that's
that seems to be the next step of
society
just further into the hall
further into the pit i'm sorry to show
this to you i feel like i'm no showing
you something i'm actually fascinated by
it i don't get freaked out i don't get
freaked out by this stuff because i'm a
i'm a very realistic person so i don't
get like oh my god because i know this
is all coming it's coming like it does
nothing i went to basil in miami and i
spent 48 hours there and i felt again
like i had swallowed a sheet of acid
but everything that they talked about
was real they go listen everything your
kids are gonna want like instead of a
pair of prada sunglasses
or you know jimmy choo shoes or a
porsche
everything for clout that they're gonna
want for
to show off it's gonna all be digital
they're gonna want to buy things for
their digital world
yeah
it doesn't freak me out because nothing
shocks me anymore ship station if you're
running an online business right now and
who isn't you need to use ship station
you don't need to worry about the back
office shipping you can save time by
funneling all your orders into one
simple interface no matter what you're
selling manage every order amazon ebay
etsy your own website from anywhere even
your phone no more headaches from
dealing with returns and return traffic
ship station makes it easy
save money when you compare carrier
options and choose the best shipping
solution every time ship station works
with every carrier you can always find
the best fit for you your business can
access the same discounted rates usually
reserved for fortune 500 companies save
your sanity knowing your orders are
handled and you're getting the best
rates make shipping easy by having an
online store you have bigger ideas to
think about no wonder 98 of companies
use ship station
for a year
keep using it for as long as they're in
business so if you do it for a year you
just keep it forever it's that good [ __ ]
more and less time with ship station use
my offer code tim dillon to get a 60-day
free trial that's two months free of no
hassle stress free shipping amazing if
you're starting a business you want to
save a little bit of money just go to
shipstation.com and click on the
microphone at the top of the page and
type in tim bill and ship station make
ship happen for most of us learning a
second language in high school or
college wasn't exactly the high point of
our academic careers i could only
pronounce the food things helato means
ice cream now thanks to babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just don't want to look
like an idiot babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons you'll actually use in
the real world babel's 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lesson plans were
created by over 100 language experts
their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation and accent
there are so many ways to learn with
babel in addition to lessons you can
access podcast games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20 day money back guarantee start your
new language learning journey today with
babel right now save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to babble.com
tim that's babel.com tim for 60 off your
subscription it's true i'm embarrassed i
only know english i want to know another
language most kids growing up today and
other countries are bilingual
so get on this folks do it do the babel
it's language for life and especially if
you're going to go abroad and you should
i am learning russian i always wanted to
learn russian it seems like a great time
because as soon as i learn it i'm going
to get over there and straighten it all
out babble language for life if you ever
you know it's interesting did you ever
perform
because you've been in new york comedy
for so long
you never performed for trump or
anything right no because they like hate
comedy
like those types of people but i always
wonder like because you've been such a
new york staple for a very long time
you've probably seen
a lot of like politicians kind of
interesting people yeah no i've never um
i've never performed for like very big
politicians
right lower lower level but not huge
huge politicians no yeah
have you
ed mangano the nassau county executive
who was indicted for taking bribes uh
him and his wife were uh getting free
deli platters no i swear to god ed
mangano and his wife were
she was she was given a 300 000 job as a
food tester at a deli so that's like
long island corruption yeah yeah no i
haven't
but
yeah i'm trying to think i mean there's
been like people in the audience but no
one
major yeah
yeah when you hate l.a
i don't i don't hate it i i'm okay with
it it's you know like for short periods
but if i were to ever live here i'd have
to have a job like i'd have to be on a
show or something i could never live
here and just like try to make it right
yeah it's tough
where in the country do you perform
that's outside of the coast that you
really like is there a place where you
go i really like to be there
outside of the coast see to me i love
i love working people so i spend most of
my time in beverly hills and the
hamptons
because i like working here yeah i get
it i it doesn't but i like people that
have you know that that work so i like
beverly hills the hamptons palm beach
yeah but now outside of that
where
where
where are places in the cup but i hate
performing for rich people i don't think
they should be allowed in comedy clubs
no i they're the worst crowds there are
they're entitled and they don't like
they don't have anything they're
horrific they don't relate no i love
performing for working people yeah they
love
because they need to come out exactly
they're dying to laugh yeah they're
dying right yeah yeah they don't even
have food but i yeah
i uh they have they have food that's the
only thing we give them yeah no i'm
joking i i love like small town you know
places where they're they don't have a
lot of entertainment like you know they
have that comedy club and they go out
and they're dying to laugh and yeah yeah
totally um there's a bunch of places
around the country that i i love to
perform in yeah um
your live act is one because there's
people that comedy seller the biggest
comedians in the world hate following
you yeah because you are the one of the
biggest powerhouses on stage ben's like
have you ever had a follower i'm like
thank god no that's very sweet i'm like
no whenever we performed jessica was
always headlining we were performing in
churches in queens for crackheads
and jessica was the head i was just
doing 10 minutes very excited i'll never
forget i saw you there and was blown
away
you're [ __ ] amazing well that's very
sweet of you i thought you were great
that night do you know how long ago that
was we're talking 10 years it was a long
time ago and i saw you and i'm like he
is
really funny i mean you were really
really funny when i saw it well i just
got into comedy hard and i destroyed
any chance of you know decent
relationships and everything i let
everything go by the wayside for comedy
yeah you were great i thought right away
i thought he's a great comic and you've
always everyone has always said i'm
talking from years back yeah well
everyone thought you were great right
away this is a script we wrote for
jessica she's doing very well we went
off over all of this in the car yeah
you're reading yourself a teleprompter
in the studio right now yeah people
thought you were great they really loved
you from right away no they did everyone
has said that about you well you have a
very good reputation yeah yeah for sure
i hope you do yeah you do i mean
you're brilliant i'm not just saying
that to be nice you really that's very
to be this
it's not just with comedy i mean you
have a brilliant mind and that's why
you're so successful it's with fitness
you're very smart yes you heard a lot of
things yeah you're great with dumbbells
yeah no i i'm good with fitness yeah and
with fighting with mma yeah you really
that's why me and joe rogan get along we
met at the gym oh i know yes he told me
you trained him for like i trained joe
rogan and then but then he wasn't
serious about his nutrition so i had to
drop him he eats a lot of sugar
it's the never ending possibility olive
garden i know he's a [ __ ] pig that's
right well he's in a corset do you know
this this is true many people don't know
this
he's 400 pounds i know he's in a corset
so when he leaves the studio he actually
just really becomes out he becomes lizzo
it's very
liza was a new show can we can we get up
the uh trailer which is funny that
people think he's a racist because he is
lizzo right it's crazy it's wild but
lizzo has a new show now called big
girls which again another thing watch
out for my agent
could not get me on and it's called
watch out for the big girls which again
sounds like a negative but this is being
billed as a positive thing okay
i didn't even know she had a new show
it's a new show watch out for the big
girls
[Music]
what's up y'all it's lizzo i'm looking
for dancers to join me on my tour girls
that look like me don't get
representation time to pull up my
sleeves and find them myself
i should go on this because i can dance
i want to be on the show it's the battle
of the big girls
to be a background dancer for lizzo
would just mean everything
[Music]
it's show time
now here's my thing and i'm not trying
to be
i'm not trying to even make a joke
what if one of these people has a heart
attack
you mean on the audition like on the
show
it's like what if
what if
one of the episodes someone has a heart
like does
this would it give anyone pause would
they go
she'll probably get a lot more votes
right yeah right and then she comes back
she'll get sympathy votes yeah she comes
back in and april plays a valve um
i i
i think
[Laughter]
it's a fair i'm just a fair question
i mean i think that you know
someone could have a heart attack yeah
it's a very good possibility it's very
stressful someone could do a split and
[ __ ] everywhere because they ate so much
i mean
a lot of things could happen yeah
someone could have you know a stroke i
mean there's a there's so many
different things that could happen so my
whole thing is just it's an interesting
and this episode it doesn't come out
next this week it'll come out next week
and this probably is already premiered
and i'm hoping that doesn't happen but
it is a possibility so many things could
happen it's a very real possibility yeah
on the show people could be vomiting
it's a physical we have no idea but it
could be a lot of crying yeah they're
you know
you could absolutely stuffing down
feelings there's so many well that's the
thing eating is a compulsion that's
emotional i wonder if they eat while
they're dancing if they could eat just
put the food down
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah but you wouldn't get disqualified
no because they you know you celebrate
being fat so they're all just shoving
cookies in their mouths while they're
twirling
it really is the end isn't it
it's it's gone it's we're in it we're
not even starting we're in the end yeah
no it's just it's a severe
it's odd to me it's odd that we we
celebrate now everybody's and i mean now
we have you know drug addicts and
we all have sympathy for drug addicts we
have empathy we know what it's like but
now we have you know people that we have
open-air drug markets in cities where
people shoot heroin on the street yeah
that's gonna be the new reality show
that'll be the one or that'll be the
next thing people will go like i'm a
proud heroin addict right i'm proud of
that right we should celebrate opioid
like i'm not addicted to opioids i
choose to use them right and it's my
lifestyle and if you have a problem with
that you're an issue right i'm going to
be an addict that chooses background
addicts yeah to to be around me yes yeah
yeah yeah that'll be the next hills
around me yeah that'll be the next show
i want a crew of people that love
fentanyl as much as i do
it but it seems like that because we're
just celebrating compulsions yeah yeah
and addictions yeah because i see this
all as is
through the mindset of an addict i go
this is all addictive behavior the food
i know i struggle with it myself i just
pictured them going on tour and just all
these dancers just falling to the ground
and dying they're gonna die
they all just go cardiac arrest yeah
they're gonna die
i mean they're gonna die and it's sad
but it's like that like it's it's sad
but we're making fun of it as people who
struggle it's like i'm i'm literally i
struggle too but i i don't go when i
make a bad food choice
i never want others to do it me either
i'm never like hey this is the way to
live no i don't want people clapping and
cheering me on i want them to get me
help i want them to help me it would be
very weird if i pulled into a mcdonald's
late night and there was people around
me cheering like i was finishing a
marathon
like that yeah like handing me nuggets
like like like you hand someone a towel
or like water like they're handing me
ketchup packets no i want you to like
help me yeah it seems to just be
a pro and i don't know why it wouldn't
eventually be drugs
right like that's the next thing yeah
like and we already kind of see it where
they're like they just don't don't
persecute people
that are doing heroin in a tent
and you go i'm not trying to persecute
anyone but it's not good for them
it's not good it's not good for tent
cities to be there
um it's not a positive thing well we
should really celebrate them right
because you know right at least well
yeah
well that's what people do
you know people do and they go you know
we and it's like so to me it's like that
may be the next reality show it's just
you know people in the tents yeah i
think it was we're we're we're maybe a
year away from the first homeless
celebrity
like a homeless star
you know what i could see it yes
for sure a homeless reality show yes
where they're like a star
yeah and they're you know
and they're they're known i guarantee
there's gonna be one in la oh we'll be
ground zero and it'll be it'll be people
that are kind of like hey i i love this
because there are there is a whole thing
now where they go well if we offer you a
bed
and you
and we offer you a home and you you
don't accept it
we can't allow you to stay
on the streets and then people go know
that you can't do that
you have to let people
camp on the street yeah you have to
listen not only that but you need to let
like give them lighting you need to give
them a kitchen yes yeah yeah den you
have to let that porch you have to yes
you have to let them be on the street if
they so choose to stay on the street and
use drugs and they don't want to live in
the thing so we're getting to a point
now where why not
you know why not celebrate everything
yeah you know and it's a bit it's a bit
scary
because
i've made a lot of mistakes my i've
never celebrated like i've never been
like you know what's a good idea stay in
the closet till 25 do cocaine
drink
quit that and then eat a lot i've never
said that's the way to do it i've never
said i'm a bad [ __ ]
that's why i did that i said i did that
because i was in a lot of pain it was
very hard and i didn't find something i
liked to do and then i finally found
something i like to do and i i
transitioned out of that behavior most
of that behavior
but yeah because you want to try to help
other people and you want to explain to
people that it's not a great decision
and you don't want it to be celebrated
you want to like be an example and try
to
you know yeah
i know yeah
i again i don't feel like uh
fat people should be made fun of or
ridiculed or anything but but it's i
don't also feel like it should be
celebrated because it's not healthy it's
not healthy that's why i'm trying
something people would disagree with you
they go it actually is no it's not i
know
no it's not i
when i was that large had high blood
very high blood pressure i felt very
sick i my cholesterol was hot i was not
well i was very sick i was not doing
well physically now i'm like
everything's good right
but my back was out my knee was killing
me
yeah so you're saying to be 500 pounds
is a detriment to your health because
that that is a controversial statement
in some corners of the internet
yeah but there are people there
there are people that go
you can be three four five hundred
pounds and it doesn't have any negative
health effects i know those people need
help
they really this is what i'm talking
about those people really need and how
do you help them how do we help them you
can't you can't they need to be put down
when i say that i mean that and i'm
joking right they cannot be helped it
doesn't seem like a zombie movie yeah
there's no you can't convince people
there's a lot of people i now
that are going to believe what they want
to believe and they're stuck in that and
there's no way of convincing that you
know that right you can't convince these
people they just go to the medivh
they're done that's it they just go to
the people are stuck in their beliefs
and you cannot to try and convince them
that that's their
no
it is healthy to be 500 pounds you're
wrong what am i going to try to convince
it's a waste of energy they're done
right they're gone right buy great right
yep blow up you're healthy do you think
you'll stay in long island forever no
yeah
but right now i'm on the road so much
right and that's where danielle's family
is so it's like they what do you think
because i know my eventual and i don't
know when it is it might be years and
years down the line my eventual thing is
probably the west coast of florida
yeah i i will i always grew up in
florida i mean my gran both grandmothers
or the east coast i don't know but
florida i think florida i love florida i
love it i mean i'm there a lot i like we
have a place in delray
yeah so my family so i'm there i was
just there and i'm going back next week
i mean i just came from there the other
day
um yeah i love florida i i uh but i will
i think we're all going to end up in
like a a home with guns and you know
just
like mining our business and protecting
our home and our families because this
world is i don't know what's happening
yeah what a positive note i know i
really think exactly i know i just
wanted everyone to feel safe and okay
yeah while we were ending this yeah well
you're gonna everyone's gonna spend
time and at home with their guns and
their family well look what's going on
yeah but i don't mean now enjoy yourself
now everyone blow up [ __ ] your face
get as fat as you can and celebrate it
yeah yeah
it's crazy where are where can people
find your live dates because i'm not
kidding you have one of the best live
acts i've ever seen and it's well worth
it's well worth people to go see you
um
and support you because i'm in in terms
of live comedy there's really nobody
really doing it better thank you you can
go to jessicakerson.com
yup
jessicakerson.com k-i-r-s-o-n i have a
tick tock that you would love cause i
post crowd work videos every day um and
a lot of you know a lot of people do
crowd work a lot of women don't so i
purposely do it a lot so i have a tick
tock jessica carson and i'm on instagram
jessie kersen but i'm on the road i'm on
tour for months coming up and i'm doing
a lot of different cities how do you do
it do you ever take a break not now
right i'm really on tour right now i'm
not like you are jesus it's insane what
you're doing well i'm done in may right
but you're a [ __ ] warrior it's
amazing um but no i'm touring a lot
coming up and i have a lot in the fall
so i'm happy you know i'm i'm doing a
lot it's good yeah i mean the the live
shows are great
uh
you go to jessica's website she's got
her podcast up there patreon
you have everything uh up there easy
jessica kirsten.com jessiekay
on instagram and really go out to see a
live show because th you're you know i
don't recommend a lot of comics live
um
but you really are like the gold
standard of a new york comedian like you
know which is the the highest honor
boston new york like
comedy is an east coast thing that's
just what it is you know i mean people
can
get angry about that and not like that
but that's absolutely the truth but
thank you so much for coming on we
rarely have guests i know and you like
just texted me and said come on and you
know yeah i can't tell you how much i
appreciate that it's like
you know you've done that and joe and
you know bill burr like people who've
really reached out to help me and i
can't it just means a lot yeah jessica
kierson right there on instagram
uh
yeah it means a lot because i respect
you so much and you've done something
that
is just incredible and uh
and you know
that you texted me and said you should
be selling out stadiums you should and
everybody believes that and you will be
it's just it's just people
figuring it out you know and just
basically
you know
coming around you know yeah and uh but
but i mean i watch you tonight at the
lab factory and again it's like
i mean ben is such a massive fan of you
and uh
every time you're in town we go watch
you you know yeah we go watch you and
then
you know we're like thank god i'm like
thank god i don't have to follow jessica
i could just go yell in a room
well you kill two i do good thank god i
mean people don't want to follow you
either i mean we have strong acts we
[ __ ] command a room and that's you
know people don't want to follow you
either
the concern for me has always been
when people see me on stage
they go
i've always felt i think the struggle
that i have is being being
too hot to get laughs
that is word on the street where people
see me and they go he doesn't need it i
know you know what i mean he doesn't he
doesn't need this the problem is when
you're that attractive people are
looking at you and want to [ __ ] you
my dermatologist called me today just to
check up so that's where i'm at
i had a dermatologist call me from
orange county to just check up on me he
goes i've seen your instagram you have
something going on on your face oh my
god that's not good no i swear to god
it's a dermatologist orange county goes
something's going on on your face
we should biopsy it i go oh that's nice
i said i'm on the road can we do it
later he goes yeah but i'll call in a
prescription so we called it a
prescription of ralph's in the ghetto
and i went and got a prescription and i
put it on my face tonight i don't know
what it is
it's it's
probably
yeah so i mean that that's that's where
i'm at
yeah i know he closed prescriptions in i
think he wants me to take care of you
he wants me to get killed because he's
always trying to save me money you can
go to get your skin medication you get
shot in the head yeah no he's always
trying to like save me money
so he like calls in scripts to like
these like horrible places
okay
follow jessica goes to your live
everybody we're on tour too who gives a
[ __ ] we got one month left and it's over
go away thank you